Is it okay to take diatomaceous earth food grade for extra cleansing if you have breast cancer?
General answer to that is yes, it is. If you haven't started it, now
the only recommendation of that is to start at a lower dose. Start maybe a teaspoon a day
for a period of time and you can work up to maybe a tablespoon a day or something.
But no, there's no really negatives to that. Diatomaceous earth is really a binder
more than anything else. It can help sweep the gut similar to SBI Pro,
but Mudo-Globe let's help decrease the inflammation probably a little better
than diatomaceous earth. But diatomaceous earth acts more as a binder in the gut, which is good.
It's fine, that's it can be an anti-parasite in the gut as well. So yeah, it can be a good thing to do.
There's no downsides to that. Some people can have sensitivities to it.
Maybe it just doesn't do well with them, and I don't think it's like an antibody sensitivity,
but I think it just is an irritant. So just I would start slow with it.